la vérité éclatera t-elle enfin dans le
procès en appel de l'affairé d'outreau
hier l'un des six accusés a été mis hors
de cause quand des enfants victimes
d'abus sexuels dans cette affaire ont
avoué l'avoir injustement accusé
aujourd'hui l'expert psychologue qui
avait donné foi aux propos des enfants
étaient sur la sellette
nathalie cause guy sam
dominique viel s'est toujours dit
innocent victime d'une rumeur colportée
par les enfants ce prêtre ouvrier a été
incarcéré 28 mois puis condamné à sept
ans pour viol aujourd'hui le ferais très
souriant comme sa famille les trois
enfants qu'il accusait lancinant
semblait hier soir j'ai menti affirmé
gabriel 12 ans j'ai dénoncé la baie pour
faire comme les copains ont eu très peur
parce que j'ai eu très peur qu'il ay pas
jusqu'au bout je sentais on s'entraide
ailleurs la présidente possible elle
sentait que il avait quelque chose à
dire et à ce moment là je me suis dit ça
tient à un fil
abba euros cet expert psychologue avait
jugé les accusations des enfants
crédible il s'est trompé attaqué
aujourd'hui par la défense il se
justifie je suis assis savait mais une
expertise psychologique s'est payé
actuellement aux environs de 15 euros de
l'heure
alors quand on paye des expertises et
arié de femmes de ménage en à des
expertises des femmes de ménage la
parole des enfants est fragile explique
ce psychiatre
les experts ne doivent plus se prononcer
sur leur crédibilité
c'est un concept qui est trop dangereux
parce qu'il conduit à confondre
encore une fois la véracité et la
cohérence et on ne peut pas demander à
l'expert d'être à la fois un expert
psychiatre psychologue et puis de
remplir la mission de la police et des
juges donc l'expert ne peux pas répondre
à la question de la culpabilité dans
cette affaire le juge aussi a commis des
erreurs pendant l'instruction il n'a
jamais organisé de confrontation entre
les enfants et les accusés et il a
refusé toutes les contre expertise
demandée par la défense
et puis dans le pro